The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK, let's start.
So back to our Ising model.
And for this lecture, focusing
mostly on a square like this.
At each side, we have
a binary variable.
And a weight that tries
to keep neighboring
the sides to be parallel.
So every pair of
neighboring sides
is subject to a joined
fate such as that.
You're going to ignore
the magnetic field.
And to calculate a
partition function,
we have to sum over r 2 to the
n configuration on both sides.
And this will be a partition
function that will [INAUDIBLE]
on this one parameter k, which
is some energy divided by kt.
So then what we did
was you we rewrote
each one of these factors as
a hyperbolic cosine 1 plus
tangent and took out
all of the factors
of the hyperbolic
cosine in the outside.
And for the case of
this square lattice,
each side has two bonds
going out of that.
So there's 2 to the n,
and I'll have to sum r 2
to the n configurations
product of what all bonds.
These factors of 1
plus t sigma i sigma j,
where this T is, of
course, my shorthand
for hyperbolic function.
Now we saw that basically
what we need to do
is either we take 1--
that's the t right there--
or terms that have these
factors of t sigma sigma.
But in order to ensure that
they will survive the summation
over the two possibilities of
sigma, each one of these terms
has to be matched
with another one.
And so the most trivial diagram
would be something like this.
And then sum over the two
possibilities at each side
will give us a
factor of n per side.
So you have 2 to the n
[INAUDIBLE] to the power of 2n.
And then we have a sum over
graphs which have zero, two,
or four bonds
emanating per site.
So that this summation
over the sigmas
will give us a factor of
2 and another factor of 0.
And then we just have
to count t to the power
of the number of
1's in the graph.
Now we said that all
of the exciting things
have to do with this sum, which
depends on this parameter t,
of course.
And this sum, as
written here, has
graphs such as the one
that I indicated, but also
potentially graphs that
are more complicated which
each have these joined pieces.
And we've attempted to replace
this sum s with another sum, s
prime, which is the sum
over gas of phantom loops.
Let's call it multiple
phantom loops.
Essentially, if I allow
these loops to basically go
through each other, then I can
exponentiate this and write it
as a sum over all single
phantom loops thereby removing,
the factors of n squared,
n cubed, et cetera,
that will arise by moving
the destroyed pieces
all over the lattice.
This sum, since
I can essentially
pick it apart particular
loop and then slide it once
over the lattice, is certainly
extensive proportional to n.
So this would be nice.
We calculate this sum
as prime last time,
and we saw that it actually
reproduced for us the Gaussian
model.
So this was equivalent
to the Gaussian model.
And in particular,
because we were allowing
this phantom condition,
when we went to sufficiently
low temperature or when t
became sufficiently large,
essentially the
model was unstable
and because I
could just continue
to put more and
more of these loops.
There was no
condition that would
say you should have
a finite density.
And then the density of the
loops would go to infinity.
And just like the
Gaussian model,
it doesn't make sense
beyond some point.
Now mathematically,
it is clear to us
that s is not equal
to s prime because
of two important
reasons, one of which
is obvious is multiple
occupation of a bond that
is in the original sum
that I have up here.
You can see that
the contribution
of each point
connecting neighbors
is either 1 or one factor of t.
I cannot have more than that.
But when I am
calculating phantom loops
and I have
self-crossings, I have
some things that are very trial.
Like I can start and
go back on myself.
That completes a walk.
I can have things that
are more complicated.
I could have a
diagram such as this
that still involves
crossing something twice.
Or something like this
is another example.
Now all of these are
examples where I essentially
continuously moved my chalk
and drew a closed loop.
But also from the
exponentiation,
I can also generate
things that have
multiple loops, such as this
loop that does not intersect
itself but may
happen to intersect
on a bond with another loop.
So it is partly the presence
of all of these things
that allow multiple
occupation that ultimately
leads to the instability.
But I also hinted last time,
in response to a question,
that there is another mistake
that is involved not when there
is intersection at the bond,
but intersection at the site.
This leads to over-counting.
It's more subtle.
Along the diagrams
that I have in s,
we certainly complete
the good diagram
such as this one where
I have from this side
four bonds going out farther
than the usual bonds.
So this is certainly OK.
But when I want
to represent that
in terms of blocks
on the lattice,
I notice that I can
do the following.
Let's say in all cases,
I start from here,
I can start from there, I can
go and do something like this,
and come back to
my starting point.
Or I can do something like this,
and back to the starting point.
Or I could have a
diagram that would appear
at the second order in the
expansion of the exponential
that I have that involves two
loops that would correspond
to the same geometry.
So this thing that should
have been counted once
is really being
counted three times.
And so that's a mistake
to be corrected.
And actually, the reason
for this factor of three
goes back to this
Gaussian model that I
said that essentially
what amounts to is
that we are replacing
Ising variables over here
with these Gaussian
variables, s.
And so we arrange things
such that the average of s
squared was 1, so that
the sides were reproducing
the things that I had before.
But then for
something like this,
I need to know the
average s to the fourth.
And if you use
Wick's theorem, you
can quickly see that the
average of s to the fourth
is three times
average of s squared,
so you get a factor of 3 here.
That's the origin
of the factor of 3.
And indeed, if you had gone and
done rather than one component,
s, something that
was n component,
you could convince yourself
that this becomes n plus 2.
And that's consistent
whenever you
see something that has a
loop having a factor of n,
something that we
had seen in we were
doing this
diagramatic expansion.
OK, so that's a problem.
So s is not equal to s prime.
But I want to make the
following very nice assertion
that s is indeed the sum
over multiple phantom loops,
just like I had written
for s prime with a couple
of important constraints.
The constraints are--
maybe I should write them
in red-- with no U-turns.
That is, you are not going to
allow anything such as this
or this when you
would go forward
and then immediately
step backward.
That's what I will
call a U-turn.
No U-turn is allowed.
And more importantly,
with a factor of minus 1
to the number of crossings.
So what do I mean by crossing?
If you follow what I did
in drawing this diagram,
you can see that
there was a path
that I drew that never
crossed itself, whereas here I
kind of had to jump
over where I was.
I indicated that.
So according to this
rule, this diagram
will get a factor of minus.
These two diagrams don't
have any self-crossings.
They give factors of plus.
And you can see that at
least this particular diagram
is resolved.
And you can see
that this continues
to more complicated things.
Let's say that I have a
perfectly good diagram that
is something like this that
involves two crossings.
And then I can break it
roughly into two process,
and each piece I can decompose
as I had done before.
Let's see, the left part I can
either do this without crossing
or I could cross or I could have
this part as a separate loop
from this half.
And then I can join
it on the other side
with essentially any one of
these things like this, which
comes with a plus; this,
which comes with a minus;
or this one that
comes with a plus.
So you can see that
this particular diagram
of s in s prime would arise
in nine possible ways.
So I would have had
an over-counting
by a factor of a three-paired
crossing or nine total,
except that now when I
assign these factors,
some of these diagrams will
come with minus, some of them
will come with plus.
But ultimately, only
one will survive.
This is it.
All of them survive, then the
net contribution is just 1,
which is the correct on.
Now let's see.
So this removed problem B. so
this was problem B resolved.
Let's see about our
problem A, which
had to do with
multiple occupation
of the particular bond.
So these are diagrams that
will appear in s prime
that have no counterpart in s.
That is, let's say
there is this bond that
is occupied twice,
so that would be
a contribution by a
factor of t squared.
And then this part can go
and join whatever it wants.
This part can go and
do whatever it wants.
The point is that for
every diagram such as this,
I can construct a diagram
where I leave everything out
here exactly as it
was, everything out
here exactly as it was,
except that the two terminals
that I'll have to the
left and the two terminals
that I have to the right of the
bond, rather than joining them
this way, I'll join
them like this.
So this complicated diagram, as
far as this bond is concerned,
I can prescribe in two different
ways using graphs of s prime.
And one of them with
respect to the other
has an additional
factor of minus 1,
and so they give me this 0.
And you can convince yourself
that the same construction will
hold if I have three terminals,
four terminals-- it doesn't
matter.
I will do it for one
pair and it will be OK.
The only time that I
wouldn't have been able to
is if I have to terminals
on one side and one terminal
on the other side,
which is these guys.
And that's what I
said no U-turns.
So now that's taken
care of first.
So this problem A is
now also resolved.
So what do we have?
We have now established that
s-- let me just get a 0.
Let's define this loop star to
be the loops with no U-turns
and minus 1 to the
number of crossings.
So this star is
going to symbolize
that these two constraints
of no U-turns and minus 1
to the power of
number of crossings
are imposed in construction and
calculation of the contribution
of these objects.
So then what do I have?
I have that s is-- well,
there's possibility of no loop.
There is the one loop graphs.
There's the two
loops star graphs.
My little loop star graphs.
And just as in the
case of s prime,
I can exponentiate this as
the sum of all one stars.
And you may wonder
what happens when
I go to higher order terms.
In higher order
terms, potentially I
will generate two
of these things that
cross when I go to
a second order term.
But then any intersection
will involve two, four,
and even number.
Minus 1 to an even
number is one,
so there is really no
additional interaction
to worry about if multiple
things are crossing each other.
So we could exponentiate that
s of t that we have over there.
We are interested
in taking the log
of the expression for
the partition function.
I will do the factor of n log
2 hyperbolic cosine squared,
because there are essentially
two bonds per side.
And then I have a sum
over these loop stars.
Essentially, I took the
log of the expression
that I had before.
Now this sum-- well,
let's sort of take
care of this factor of n.
So I divide by n.
Log z divided by n is log of 2
hyperbolic cosines [INAUDIBLE]
k plus-- well, the way to
get rid of the factor of n
in this sum is to fix
one point of this loop
so that it doesn't go
all over the place.
So let's say that I
have the number of loops
that start and
end at the origin.
I would have to sum over
the length of those loops,
and those things will give
me a factor of t to the l.
So I have defined this n star
of l to be number of loop stars
from 0 to 0 in l steps.
So in place of this--
actually, maybe
I will emphasize it's minus
1 to the number of crossings
and no U-turns.
Now gain, so what I have
is my entire lattice.
Let's say I have in loop
that is of length 4.
And now I have forced it to
start and end at the origin
so that I can put
out this factor of n.
But then I realized that I
could have over-counted this
because this loop could have
been started from here, here,
here, here and
translated to the origin.
So just as we saw for the
case of the random walk loops
before, there is this
factor of l to correct.
And then I'm
talking about walks,
I can either go clockwise
or counterclockwise,
so I have to divide by a
factor of 2 to get rid of that.
AUDIENCE: Question?
PROFESSOR: Yes?
AUDIENCE: So what
happens if you have when
you're doing your
exponential loops
and we have one loop
nested inside another loop
that you're multiplying
together so that they
share one of their edges.
It seems like then they
don't have to cross twice,
and so you would still need
something to cancel them out.
PROFESSOR: OK, I should
have maybe explained
that graph a little bit more.
But let's do it over here.
So when I exponentiate s--
what am I calling it?--
s sum of the loops, among the
terms that I will generate will
certainly be
something like this.
And then you say this one is
shared between the two of them.
At the level of one
loop graphs, there
was a one-loop object
that went like this.
So the statement
that I made here
does not necessarily map the
number of loops to each other,
but it is correct,
and the cancellation
occurs at the level of one.
And actually, I should
have also indicated
what's happening
with the other graph
that I have up there
because I have this graph.
So that's a one-loop graph,
that cancels against this graph.
So whatever you do, you can just
follow the rule that I gave you
and ensure that the
cancellation works, of course.
So Thank.
You.
I wanted to say this
and I had forgot.
OK, any other questions?
OK, so essentially we are back
to some extent of the formula
that I had for
ordinary random walks.
And phantom loops these
are partly phantom loops,
but I have to take care
of something like this.
What did I go originally
last lecture, rather than
my ordinary graphs to
these phantom loops?
The reason was that
for a phantom loops,
I said that I had this
Markovian condition.
I could relate l step walks
to l minus 1 step walks
because there was no memory.
I didn't have to know
where I had crossed before.
But it seems that in order
to give a correct date
to these new loops,
I have to know
how many times I cross myself.
And c by itself is a
non-Markovian thing.
It requires memory.
Expect that I don't need any c.
I need only the parity of
the number of crossings.
And here is where there's a
beautiful mathematical theorem
that tells us here in
this memory-like problem
for something that is Markovian.
And the statement is a
theorem of Whitney's which
states that the
parity of a planar
loop-- the thing
that I've done here--
whether it's even or odd.
Parity of the
number of crossings
is related to the total angle
through which the tangent
vector turns by the following.
In C mod 2, which is the
parity of the crossings,
is 1 plus this
total angle that I
will call theta
divided by 2 pi mod 2.
So I'm not going to
give a proof of this,
but I will show you examples to
make sure you understand what's
happening by, let's say,
comparing the following two
graphs, one of which has no
crossing and another one which
is essentially the same
thing but has a crossing.
So basically I put
an arrow so that I
can follow where the
orientation of the bond, which
is the location of this
tangent s, as I step.
Let's say from the origin, this
is the first step, second step,
third step, fourth step,
so on and so forth.
So let's do this
for the upper graph.
And what I will do is
I will plot the angle.
And the first step here, I start
at 0 degrees pointing this way.
So this is my step number one.
At the next, I have
gone to 90 degrees,
so this is where I go to.
At three, I'm back
to pointing along
the horizon in the direction.
At four, I have
gone back up here.
At five, I go to 180 degrees.
At six, I go all the way down.
At seven, I go back
to this horizontal.
At eight, I go back
to pointing down.
And then I'm back to one.
So if you follow what
that tangent is doing,
it's going woop, woop.
At the end of the day, it
has turned through 3 pi.
So in this case, the
total turn is 2 pi.
1 plus the total turn
divided by 2 pi in this case
is 1 plus 2 pi over 2
pi, which is 2-- mod
2 which is the same thing as 0.
And of course, how many times
has this thing crossed itself?
Zero times.
So let's see how
it works if you go
to apply the same set of
rules to this other one.
So again, one, two, three,
four, five, six, seven, eight
are my steps.
One is pointing in the
horizontal direction.
Two goes vertical
just as before.
Three stays the same
place, so two and three
are at the same point.
Four, I go back to horizontal.
Five, I go down to
minus 90 degrees.
Six, I go all the
way to 180 degrees
and stay there at seven.
Eight, I go back to
minus 90 degrees,
and then rejoin the origin.
So this goes up, down, back,
never completes a full turn.
So in this case, theta is 0.
1 plus theta over 2 pi
is 1, and the number
of crossings of his graph is 1.
So you can go and repeat
this for any graph
that you like and convince
yourself that this rule works.
Well, how does that help us?
Well, the diagrams
that I have drawn here
already tells you
how it helps us
because in order to
find the total angle,
all I need to do is to keep
track of local changes.
So essentially, as I go
along, I carry a bag with me
which adds the changing
angle at every step.
I don't need to know where
I was 100 steps before.
I just add another
changing angle.
By the time I get
to the last stop,
I figure out what my total
angle is, and then I'm done.
AUDIENCE: Yes?
So is it really the
total angle that
matters, or is it more
just the number of circles
that you complete or not?
PROFESSOR: They
are the same thing.
So if you prefer
to say it in terms
of the entanglement of your loop
and the point at the origin,
that's another way of saying it.
This entity divided by 2
pi is a topological number,
which counts essentially
the number of times
you have gone around the origin.
So what I'm saying is that minus
1 to the power of the number
of crossings-- this factor
that I was after-- I can write
as e to the i pi times
the number of crossings.
And it is evident that the
only thing that is important
here is the parity, so I
can replace into the i pi
the number of crossings with 1
plus this total angle divided
by 2 pi.
Which means I have
e to the i pi, which
is a factor of minus 1.
And then I have e to
the i theta over 2.
And my statement is that
this is the same thing as e
to the i over 2, sum over the
little bits of change of angle
that people have as
you go along there.
So what I have to do
is as I am walking
around this square
lattice, I better
keep track of
which direction I'm
pointing so that I know from
one step to the next step
whether I change by 0
degrees, 90 degrees,
minus 90 degrees, et cetera.
So what do I do?
I define a convention.
So we are going to introduce
orientation mu of step
as follows.
So let's say I'm at some
point on the lattice i.
Then I can increase the particle
c along one of four directions.
And I'm going to
label them by mu
being equal to 1, 2, 3, or 4.
You can choose any
notation you want.
This will be the
notation I will use.
Secondly, I'm going to introduce
the analog of the quantity
that we had for the phantom
random box, which was I
introduced a set of
matrices that were counting
how many base I can
go from one side
to another side in l steps.
So I will introduce
the following notation.
Something that involves the
starred box that involves l
steps.
And I say that I start
at some point xy and I
end at some other
point x prime y prime.
So again, just
counting how many ways
I can go from one
to another point.
Except that I also want to keep
track of these orientations.
So this quantity is
defined as follows.
It is the sum over random
walks that start at xy along m.
That is, if this
is my point, xy,
and I'm looking at the
second element of this,
the next step I have to go up.
If I have specified
that mu equals to 1,
it means that the first step
I have to go to the right.
OK, as I go further
on the lattice,
I ensure that I never
have any U-turns,
and I keep track
of the factors of e
to the i theta that changes as
I take one step to the next step
so that if I took my first
step here and then next
if I continued here,
there would be no factor.
But if I went up, I would have
a factor of e to the i pi 4.
So I keep track
of those factors.
And then I want to
end at x prime y prime
and head along mu prime.
Since I specified that
my first step will then
go along mu, when I
reach the last step,
I already know
where I came from.
But depending on
which direction I
specify I would turn to
and head for my next step,
I will get the changing angle.
So I have to include the
changing angle somewhere so
that there are l
changes in angle
so the way that I
have defined it,
it will be essentially
keeping track
of where the next
step is headed to.
So again, if I were
to draw a diagram,
I'll start with
this xy point, and I
want to arrive at
some point here--
let's say x prime y prime.
And I want to do in l steps.
And the first step, I
go along the direction
that is specified by mu.
So this is step 1, and there's
the 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10.
Let's see, the last one-- so
this would step l minus 1.
This is the last step, arrives
me at point x prime y prime.
But then I have to specify what
is the direction of mu prime
so that I keep track of the
appropriate change of angle
that I have to do
over here as well.
So this is the procedure.
Now this walk, this quantity
that I have defined for you
here, has the Markovian
property in that
if I arrive at this
point after l steps,
then after l minus one
steps, I was at one point--
x double prime, y double
prime-- from which
I took one step along some
direction-- mu double prime--
and arrived at this.
So I can write that I have to
sum over all possible locations
and orientations of
the before [INAUDIBLE].
I start from the point
xy, proceed along
direction mu for a total
of l minus 1 steps,
landing on x double
prime y double prime,
and then going in direction
to mu double prime.
So then I have a walk that
started at x double prime,
y double prime along
the direction in double
prime, which is one step has
to get me to my destination.
And once I am at
the destination,
I head along the
direction in prime.
So this is clearly
a matrix, a product.
And what I have established
is this matrix, w star
of l-- which, by the way,
is a 4n by 4n matrix,
because our n points
and 4 orientation,
so it's 4n by 4n matrix--
and I have established
that that is the product
of the matrix that I have
for one step, and the
product of the matrix that I
have for l minus 1 step.
And this object that I will
call t star essentially tells me
something about the combined
connectivity orientation
that I have for square lattice.
And since I can repeat
this many times,
I can see that I have the result
that I want, that w star of l
is simply t star raised
to the power of l.
Questions?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Have we accounted
for loops that [INAUDIBLE]
we have the square loop
of four steps and then
the same square loop of
eight steps that are exactly
on top of the four-step one?
PROFESSOR: OK, so you want me
to take this and do it again?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: OK, so
I can certainly
do something like this.
AUDIENCE: I see.
PROFESSOR: And of course,
I can do the same thing
over any of the bonds, but
they are always [INAUDIBLE].
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Doesn't
[INAUDIBLE] become kind
of like transfer
matrix [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: No.
It will reproduce the
result that Onsager had,
but the transfer
matrix that Onsager had
was it essentially going
from column to column.
Its size was 2 to the
n times 2 to the n.
This is 4n by 4n.
It is vastly smaller
matrix that I have to do.
All right, so maybe
we should just
write down what this
matrix t star is.
So t star, I said, is
this 4n by 4n matrix
that tells me how
going from some side
xy I arrive at some other
side x prime y prime.
But it also has
orientation information.
So really, I should have
four of these for this,
and four of these for this.
So it's actually a 4
by 4 matrix that I have
once I keep track
of orientations.
So let me write down the
4 by 4 matrix explicitly.
So here we have
in mu, and this mu
could be one, two, three, four--
which, again, specifically I
have indicated as this,
this, this, and this.
And along the other direction,
I can arrive at mu prime.
Once I have arrived
at the mu prime,
I can either go forward,
up, left, or down.
So essentially what
this says is start
with a side xy, head in
the horizontal direction.
Since this is a one-step
walk, after one step
I will be arriving
at some other point.
Once you arrive at that next
point, continue to [INAUDIBLE].
The next element says head
to the right and then go up.
The next element
says go to the right
and then start to the back.
The next element says go to
the right and then go down.
Now we can construct
the rest of them.
Up, right, up, up, up, left,
up, down, left, right, left, up,
left, left, left, down.
Lastly, down, right, down,
up, down, left, down, down.
So you do your
aerobic exercises,
and then in next stage is to
actually write down the numbers
that these correspond to.
So first of all, you can
see that-- I'm not sure
whether I will
have enough space,
but let's hope that I do--
that in this first row
of this matrix, your first
step was always to the right.
So always, you will start from
x and you end up at x plus 1
while y does not change.
So I will indicate that
by x plus 1-- actually,
what should I write it?
Yeah, x prime, y prime.
x prime has to be x plus 1.
y prime has to be y.
So I'll have to
introduce the notation
that x prime y prime xy
means theta x x prime delta y
y prime.
So essentially, you just
read off for x prime, y prime
what the new points have to be.
And I proceed forward.
There's no change in face.
The next one, I arrive
at the same point,
so x prime y prime
is x plus 1 y.
But now my tangent
vector, my heading
has shifted by 90 degrees, so
I have to put a factor of e
to the i pi over 4.
The next one, I try
to go back, but I've
said U-turns are not allowed,
so this matrix element is 0.
The next matrix element, I have
x prime y prime x plus 1 y.
Now I have pinned it down,
so minus 90 degrees--
the changing angle--
is minus i pi over 4.
The second column, you
can see that essentially
the y-coordinate has to
change by 1, increase by 1.
So I have x prime, y
prime being xy plus 1.
And this element has
a change of angle
that corresponds to
the minus 90 degrees,
so this is e to the
minus 5 pi over 4.
The diagonal element
continues to head straight,
so there was no phase
angle associated with that.
The third element heads
in the opposite direction,
so the phase element for that
is e to the minus i pi over 4.
The fourth element is a
U-turn, so it will be 0.
The third column starts
with a U-turn, which is a 0.
The next one, you can see
I have to step to the left,
so x prime has to become x
minus 1 while y does not change.
The phase factor is e to
the minus i pi over 4.
Along with diagonal,
there is no phase factor.
And if I already had one
e to the minus i over 4,
I should have e to the i
pi over 4 for the last one.
And the last element corresponds
to y decreasing by 1.
So I start with x prime,
y prime in xy minus 1.
The first phase
that I have to do,
I can kind of read how
things go diagonally.
This is i pi over 4
to the i pi over 4.
The next one has to be 0
because the 0's you can see,
are proceeding diagonally.
The next one would be x
prime, y prime xy minus 1
e to the i minus i
pi over 4 and then
x prime y prime xy minus
1 for the last time.
So this keeps track of
the changes in phase.
So now the next
thing that we did
when we had the ordinary
random walks was we
took advantage of the
translational invariance
of the lattice to go to Fourier
space and make diagonalization.
And indeed, we can do that over
here, too, but only partially
in that this object has
two sets of indices.
There is the lattice coordinates
and there's the orientation.
But what I can certainly do is
to diagonalize the the subspace
that corresponds to positions.
What do I mean by that?
What I will do is I will
introduce, let's say, qx, qy,
xy-- these Fourier elements--
which are e to the i qx
x plus qy y divided by square
root of n just as before,
without any
orientation component.
Then you can see that if I
multiply this object to xq
y xy, with this matrix
that I have over here,
xy t star x prime y prime,
and sum over x and y,
but leave the
orientations unchanged.
That is, basically I
do this individually
for each one of these 16
elements of this matrix
that each one of them
clearly depends on x, y,
x prime, y prime, but also
has some additional factors.
In each case, what
is going to happen
is that because I'm
shifting x or y by one step,
I will get this factor
back up to e to the i qx, e
to the minus i qx, e to the
i qy, e to the minus iqy
exactly as I was doing
before, except that I
will have to do this for
every single one of them.
So you can see that essentially
what this reproduces is
a matrix that is four by
four that depends on q,
and then I will get xy qx
of qy actually x prime y
prime because I sum
over x and y back.
So what is this
matrix, t star of q?
It is very easily constructed
from what I have over there.
Because you can see that from
the first one, what happens
is that when I see
x, I will change it
to x prime, which is x minus 1.
So from here, I will get a
factor of e to the minus i qx.
y and y prime are the same.
I don't get anything from here.
Next one, I will get e to the
minus i qx plus i pi over 4 0
e to the minus i qx
minus i pi over 4.
The next column, the y
has been shifted by 1.
So I will get e to the
minus i cube y minus i
pi over 4 e to the minus i qy
e to the minus i qy plus i pi
over 4 0.
The next level, the third one,
x prime is set to x minus 1,
so I essentially get
e to the i qx-- oops.
Third element starts
with 0, and then I'll
have e to the i qx minus
i pi over 4 e to the i qx,
and then I'll have e to
the i qx plus i pi over 4.
The fourth element is e to the
i cube y plus i pi over 4 0
into the i qy minus i
pi over 4 e to the i qy.
So in the positions space,
I have this 4n by 4n matrix
where the different sides were
connected to their neighbors
with these phase factors.
I have gone from coordinate
to Fourier basis.
I did this transformation.
Now I have a matrix that
is blocked diagonal.
So for each value of the q,
I have a four by four block.
So in the q picture, imagine
that you have this 4n
by 4n matrix, and you
have blocks of four
for different q
along the diagonal.
Each one of them is this.
So now let's go and calculate
our partition function.
So what do we have?
We have that log z over n
is log 2 hyperbolic cosine
squared of k plus
1/2 sum over l.
Sum over l of these
loops that go back
all the way to themselves.
So this is t to the l over l.
This is loop star of length l.
I want to relate
loop star of length
l to this w star
of length l, but I
want to start and
end at the origin.
So I start from the origin
and end at the origin.
But I have to be careful,
because let's say
I make a loop such as this
and I end up at the origin.
I have to get the
right phase factor.
So if I started
along direction mu,
when I get back to the starting
point, I cannot turn this way,
this way and get the
right phase factor.
I have to go and head in
the same direction as mu.
So I have to head to
the same direction.
Now I can certainly
do this as a summation
also over the starting point.
Instead, I have to
start and end at 0.
I could have started
and ended at any point,
and then I do a
sum of xy and mu,
but then I better
divide by the n, right?
And the reason I do
that is because now you
can see that the structure
of this is like a trace,
and I like that.
Actually, I made a mistake when
I did this because, you see,
the factor that I had to
really include is minus 1
to the number of crossings.
But my w l star is
just keep track of e
to the i delta thetas.
Actually, I should have put
in here a delta theta over 2.
So I had forgotten that.
But we can see that that factor
is different from minus 1
to the nc to the minus sign.
So there was that minus
sign that I had forgotten.
And actually, I better
make this a minus sign.
So what was plus before becomes
a minus because of this factor
that I have over here.
So let's write this again.
This is log 2 hyperbolic cosine
squared of k minus 1 over 2n.
And then this sum over
xy mu is like a trace.
And what is it that I'm tracing?
I'm tracing a sum over l, t
t star to the l divided by l.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So we'll also sum
it over mu [INAUDIBLE] 4?
PROFESSOR: No,
because I don't know
which direction
my first step is.
So what I'm doing is I'm
summing over all always
of starting step from the
origin, head in direction mu.
Then I have to make sure
that I come back to mu.
Now it is true
that I sum over mu,
but I already took
care of that when
I divided by 2l,
because let's say
you look at the
diagrams of length 4
that I generate
through this procedure.
Starting from here, depending
on which direction I go,
I will generate this or
this or this, or this.
These are precisely
the four diagrams
that I generate depending on
which starting point I pick.
So it is truly there
is an over-counting,
but that's an over-counting that
you've already taken care of.
Now again, we did
this last time.
This is the series
for minus log of 1
minus 2 t star-- matrix t star.
So this is the same thing as
log of 2 hyperbolic cosine
squared of k plus now 1
over 2n trace of log of 1
minus t t star.
Now I said that my matrix
was blocked diagonal
when I went to look
at the q basis.
And I can take the
trace in any basis,
whether it's in coordinate
basis, in momentum basis.
Trace is trace.
So now focus on what
the trace will look
like if I go to
the Fourier basis.
I have these four
by four blocks,
and then I calculate
the trace, I
will calculate the trace
of one four by four.
And the other four by
four, I go over all q's.
So basically this can be
written as a sum over q's.
Log of 1 minus t.
This four by four matrix t star
of q, and the trace of that.
And finally-- oops, I forgot
a factor of 1 over 2n here.
The sum over q I'm going to
replace with an integral over q
times n over 2 pi squared.
So the final answer
here is going
to look like log 2
hyperbolic cosine squared
root of k plus 1/2.
The 1 over n I will get rid
of when I write the sum over q
as n integral d2 of q.
So I have integral d2 of
1 divided by 2 pi squared.
One more step.
Trace of a log of any
matrix I can write--
let's say we find a basis
in which the m is diagonal.
Then it becomes a sum
over alpha log of lambda
alpha, where lambda alphas
are diagonal values of this.
But sum over logs
is the same thing
as log of the product over
alpha of lambda alpha.
The product of eigenvalues
of the matrix you
also recognize to
be the determinant.
So this is the log of the
determinant of the matrix.
So this is a very
useful, famous identity
that trace log is the same
thing as log determinant
that I will use.
And rather than
calculate the trace log,
I will write it as the
log of the determinant,
and I will explicitly
write down for you
the determinant of which
four by four matrix.
It is simply 1 minus p times
the elements of that matrix.
So it's 1 minus t e to
the minus i qx minus t
e to the minus i qx plus
i pi over 4 0 minus t
e to the minus i qx
minus i pi over 4.
Second element,
second row-- minus t
e to the minus i qy minus
i pi over 4 1 minus t
e to the minus i qy minus t
e to the minus i qy plus i pi
over 4 minus-- oops, 0
for the last element here.
It's a U-turn.
The third thing is 0 minus
t e to the i qx minus i
pi over 4 1 minus t e to the i
qx diagonal element minus t e
to the i qx plus i pi over 4.
Final row-- minus t e
to the i cube y plus i
pi over 4, 0 for the
U-turn, minus t e
to the i qy minus i pi over
4 diagonal turn 1 minus t e
to the i cube y, and that's it.
And that's the answer.
So calculating the
partition function
of the 2-dimensionalizing
model is
reduced to calculating this
four by four determinant, which
we can do by hand.
I won't do it here.
I will write the answer.
So the log of z over n is log
3 hyperbolic cosine squared
of k plus 1/2 integral
d2 q 2 pi squared.
Log, you take the determinant.
What you find is 1 plus t
squared squared minus 2 t 1
minus t squared cosine
of qx plus cosine of qy.
If you want, you can write it
in a slightly different way
by taking the cosine squared
inside this logarithm
and doing a little
bit of algebra.
We get log 2 plus 1/2.
Explicitly, these are integrals
that go from 0 to 2 pi,
because that's the
range of q vectors
that are allowed by
this transformation.
I'll have a q in
the x direction.
the y direction.
2 pi squared, each one of them
goes in the range 0 to 2 pi.
I have a log.
And once I take this
cosine squared inside,
it becomes cos to the fourth.
You write this t sine squared
divided by cos squared.
You can see that the cos to
the fourth will cancel this.
You will get cos squared
plus sine squared,
which is the same thing as
hyperbolic cosine of twice
the angle squared.
And the other terms conspires
to give you the sine of 2kx
and then cosine of
qx plus cosine of qy.
And so this is the
partition function
of the 2-dimensionalizing model.
You can do a little
bit more manipulations,
write this integral in
terms of special functions,
but you won't gain much.
So this is the answer.
I want you to absorb and
appreciate this derivation.
And next time we
look at this and see
what it means for the
similarities in the phase
behavior of the
2-dimensionalizing.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
in the log, it's cos
squared minus [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
But both of them went
to twice diagonal.
Here everything
is in terms of k.
And once I took the hyperbolic
cosine squared inside then
did the manipulations, they
became twice the length.
AUDIENCE: What's the subscript
up there [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: 2.
There should be
a subscript, yes.
AUDIENCE: Is there an
extension to higher dimensions
where you just do a
summation over cosine?
PROFESSOR: You
would wish, right?
I mean, that's actually--
[LAUGHTER]
PROFESSOR: And quite
a number of people
have come with that
conjecture, including
myself when i was
a graduate student
and I didn't know better.
If you sort of write
things in terms of not only
if you make kx and
ky to be different,
then this takes the
form of cos 2kx cos 2ky.
This becomes, in some
sense, a very nice version
of 2kx and 2ky.
There is a way natural--
and the thing that is nice
is that if you put any one
of the 2kx's to 0, then
you have reduced the formula for
the 1-dimensionalizing model,
as you should.
And then the natural
thing would be
to write a similar product
in three dimensions,
and you did when said
one of k's equals to 0.
You get the corrected
dimensionalizing model.
So it passes a number of test,
yet it's unfortunately not
correct.
AUDIENCE: So the
problem is conditional
in this three dimensions
is counting the loops?
PROFESSOR: What we
relied on heavily
was this factor of
minus 1 to the product
of the number of crossings.
And if you think about it
as a topological entity,
these crossings only make
sense in two dimensions.
So you don't have the basic
tool to go in three dimensions.
And actually, what
those minus signs
mean I will explain next time.
Has something to do with
fermionic character of this
[INAUDIBLE].
So it's a beautiful result.
You should appreciate it.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
this Thursday?
PROFESSOR: I'll go
through the history, too.
The person who first
derived this field energy
was Onsager with this transfer
matrix method that I described.
This way of doing it in terms
of graphs came much later.
And a number of people
that were involved
that, including Feynman.
In fact, in Feynman's
book, there's
a very nice derivation along
these lines that you can see.
The connections to fermions and
the number of people Mattis,
Schultz, Lieb, et
cetera, came up with.
One thing that-- well, OK,
guess I have a few minutes.
I can say a few things.
So this result dates
back to around 1950s.
And I know a generation
of physicists
who are now about to retire
or have retired in the past 10
years or so who were very
young when these things were
introduced.
And as far as I can see,
all through their life,
they did versions of this.
So you can sort of do versions
of the 2-dimensionalizing model
and you can make the
interactions to be different.
You can play the different
types of interactions.
You can make the
boundaries to be
different, periodic, et cetera.
There's been variants
that you can find,
and there are some
people who seem
to have done that
throughout their career.
But then after that, we had
the renormalization group,
and a totally
different perspective.